This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A couple of years ago, we presented a story produced by Paragren Andrews about how certain sounds, like the sounds of skis on a cross-country track, or hoofbeats on a horse racing track, were faked on sports broadcasts. It ended up being one of our most popular and provocative episodes ever, meaning because people really taken it back by the notion that any part of a sporting event might be faked. That episode was just a small excerpt of a much longer documentary called The Sound of Sport. And we got a number of requests from our audience over the years asking where they could hear the entire piece. And today, my friends, we are going to present it to you in its full glory. This is a fascinating, exquisitely produced, deep, deep dive into the sound design of
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。几年前，我们播放过由帕雷格林·安德鲁斯制作的一个故事，关于某些声音（比如越野滑雪赛道上的滑雪板声，或是赛马场上的马蹄声）是如何在体育转播中被伪造出来的。这最终成了我们历史上最受欢迎且最激进的单集之一，因为人们对体育赛事的任何部分可能是伪造的这一概念感到非常震惊。那一集只是一个长得多的纪录片《体育之声》的一小部分。多年来，我们收到了听众的大量请求，询问他们能在哪里听到完整的内容。今天，我的朋友们，我们将以最完整的面貌呈现给你们。这是一次迷人、精美制作、极其深入的探讨，聚焦于......
sports broadcasting. A subject that I've met most people have never even considered before. That's just one of the reasons why I love it. Keep in mind, this was a rivently broadcast in 2011, so it's after the World Cup in South Africa and before the London Olympic Games in 2012, so just to place you in the proper sports history context. This is The Sound of Sport, produced by Peregrine Andrews for voluntary productions and presented by Dennis Baxter.
体育转播的声音设计。这个话题我发现大多数人以前甚至都没有考虑过。这只是我热爱它的原因之一。请记住，节目最初是在2011年播出的，所以它发生在南非世界杯之后、2012年伦敦奥运会之前，这只是为了让你们置身于正确的体育历史背景中。这就是《体育之声》，由佩雷格里恩·安德鲁斯为志愿制作公司制作，由丹尼斯·巴克特主持。
I like listening to sports. I can close my eyes. I can hear every single one in my head. It's my belief that people have ingrained in them a memory of certain sounds, and if that sound is not fulfilled, then the mind knows that there's something wrong. There is an expectation of what football sounds like, and it certainly wasn't. The vizellas, the plastic of the World Cup in South Africa and those damn Vuvuzillas. For many people, this was the first time they'd really thought about how sports to sound. But it's what I spend my life thinking and dreaming about. I'm Dennis Baxter, and I design the sound of sports for television. For nearly 20 years,
我喜欢听体育节目。我可以闭上眼睛，在脑海中听到每一个声音。我相信人们内心深处都对某些声音有记忆，如果这种声音没有出现，那么大脑就会知道出问题了。人们对足球听起来应该是什么样有一种期待，而它绝对不是那种声音。呜呜祖拉，南非世界杯上的塑料喇叭，还有那些该死的呜呜祖拉。对许多人来说，这是他们第一次真正思考体育听起来应该是什么样。但这却是我毕生思考和梦想的事情。我是丹尼斯·巴克特，我为电视设计体育节目的声音。近20年来，
I've worked exclusively on the Olympics as their staff sound designer and engineer. I decide how to capture each event sonically so that it brings as much drama and excitement into the home as possible. They get away at first time, Paul has got a very good start, so did Dexel. I'm gearing up for London 2012. It is going to be a big job. I'll be using a team of 350 sound mixers, about 600 sound technicians and close to 4,000 microphones.
我一直专门从事奥运会的声音设计和工程工作。我决定如何以声音捕捉每个赛事，尽可能地将戏剧性和兴奋感带入千家万户。他们起步很顺利，保罗开局非常好，德克塞尔也是。我正在为2012年伦敦奥运会做准备。这将是一项巨大的工作。我将使用一个由350名调音师、大约600名声音技术人员和近4000个麦克风组成的团队。
It's a new, long record! I was born in Atlanta, Georgia, 1954, and essentially I think that I've been a sound person my entire life. When I was about eight or nine years old, my dad bought me a cassette recorder, and I was recording everything. I would go into the bathroom, my mom would be on the toilet, and I would just pop in with the microphone and start recording her. Monkle had a restaurant, and I washed an awful lot of dishes, and when I was 14 years old,
这是一个新的长纪录！我于1954年出生在佐治亚州亚特兰大，基本上我认为我一辈子都是个声音人。当我八九岁的时候，我爸爸给我买了一个盒式录音机，我什么都在录。我会走进浴室，我妈妈正在上厕所，我就会拿着麦克风冲进去开始录音。蒙克开了一家餐馆，我洗了大量的盘子，当我14岁的时候，
had enough money to buy a real real recorder. It was around $1,000 at the time. It was a staggering sum in 1968. This is the size of a big suitcase. I couldn't drive, so I used to hitchhike and carry that record to the churches and to the high schools and record just about anything that I could possibly record. I was a veteran so I went to school on my GI Bill and studied economics. They taught me a lot about borrowing money.
有了足够的钱买一台真正的录音机。当时大约要1000美元。在1968年，这是一笔惊人的巨款。这个录音机有一个大行李箱那么大。我还不会开车，所以我经常搭便车，把那个录音机带到教堂和高中，尽可能地录下我能录的一切。我是一名退伍军人，所以我靠《退伍军人权利法案》上学并学习经济学。他们教给我很多关于借钱的知识。
So at the end of my college degree, I had done my final papers on a recording studio and had convinced a bank to loan me the money and before I knew it, I was several hundred thousand dollars in debt. That recording studio dream is a misguided dream that you're going to make your own music and live happily ever after. And then all of a sudden you're struggling to get people into the studio recording things that you don't want to record and frustrated with the situation. Music
所以在大学毕业时，我的毕业论文是关于一个录音室的，并说服了一家银行把钱借给我，不知不觉中，我已经背负了十几万美元的债务。录音室的梦想是一个误导性的梦想，以为你可以制作自己的音乐并从此过上幸福的生活。然后突然之间，你为了让人来录制你根本不想录的东西而苦苦挣扎，对现状感到沮丧。音乐
We're just minutes away from the first event on the ESPN schedule. In 1982, I found another and more profitable use of audio skills at the newly formed sports television channel ESPN schedule. In 1982 I found another and more profitable use of audio skills at the newly formed sports television channel ESPN. Instead of musicians now I was capturing the sound of car racing, tennis, baseball, football, whatever they sent my way. Your Majesty I humbly ask you to declare the Olympic Games of 1948 open. That was the first Olympics to be televised by the BBC, though fewer than 100,000 homes
距离ESPN赛程的第一项赛事只有几分钟了。1982年，我在新成立的体育电视频道ESPN的赛程中找到了音频技能的另一个更有利可图的用途。1982年，我在新成立的体育电视频道ESPN上，找到了音频技能的另一个更有利可图的用途。现在，我不再录制音乐家的声音，而是捕捉赛车、网球、棒球、足球以及他们送来的任何比赛的声音。陛下，我谦卑地请您宣布1948年奥运会开幕。那是第一届由BBC转播的奥运会，尽管当时拥有电视的家庭不到10万户。
had television at the time. As you can hear, there is just past Nankivo. And it's Erickson's contour to the finish. Erickson is sweet and one strand. Like how you say it's a whole strand. As you can hear, there isn't much more than commentary to be heard. Six was Bergkiss, six Bergkiss and seventh Nankivo. My own relationship with the Olympics began in 1992 when I was offered the first full-time job as a soundseater.
正如你所听到的，刚刚过了南基沃。埃里森正朝着终点冲刺。埃里森很棒，拿到了一股。就像你怎么说它是一整股。正如你所听到的，除了评论几乎没有别的声音。第六名是伯吉斯，第六名伯吉斯，第七名南基沃。我与奥运会的关系始于1992年，当时我获得了第一份全职声音总监的工作。
I went back and listened to every single sport, trying to understand why we were covering the sports the way that we were, what sounds were there, and what sounds were really missing and why. I came from music, I came from a recording studio, and I wanted to apply those techniques and standards to the live world. And one of the first things we implemented in the Olympics was a lot more close-miking. This is where you put a microphone as close as possible to the sound source. If you use this technique, you need a lot of microphone because each microphone can only capture a little piece of the whole picture. But you get more detail
我回听了每一项运动，试图理解我们为什么要以那种方式报道体育，那里有什么声音，以及什么声音真的缺失了，为什么。我出身于音乐界，我来自录音室，我想将这些技术和标准应用到现场世界。我们在奥运会上实施的第一批措施之一就是采用更多近距离拾音。这就是把麦克风尽可能靠近声源。如果你使用这种技术，你需要大量的麦克风，因为每个麦克风只能捕捉到全貌的一小部分。但你会获得更多的细节
and definition and a hell of a lot better sound. and a elbow and a better sound. The parallel bars and the uneven bars for the women's gymnastics. When you put the microphones that close to the athlete, you hear the flexing of the bar. You hear the breathing. You can even hear the rustling of the clothing. My dad was very anti-rock and roll and he goes, okay, I'll get you a guitar and I was just thrilled. Well, come Christmas morning, he got me a guitar and it was an acoustic guitar with a Chad
和清晰度，以及好得多的声音。还有双杠和女子体操的高低杠。当你把麦克风放得离运动员那么近时，你会听到杠的弯曲声。你会听到呼吸声。甚至能听到衣服的沙沙声。我爸爸非常反对摇滚乐，他说，好吧，我给你买把吉他，我当时兴奋极了。好吧，圣诞节那天早晨，他给我买了一把吉他，那是一把带有查德的木吉他
Ackon's record. And I love Chad Ackon to this day, but for the next two years after I got the acoustic guitar, all I was trying to do was make it louder. And I stumbled across the contact microphone, which is a device, a microphone that you actually can stick right onto the top of the guitar to amplify. It picks up the actual vibrations of the wood and consequently the sound of the guitar. 30 years later, I'm looking at gymnastics. The balance beam is a synthetic resin type of material that athletes, they balance on, they do somersaults, they do all kinds of routines on top of it. And I'm hearing this balanced being, I say, I mean, that has a certain resonance in there
阿肯的唱片。直到今天我都非常喜欢查德·阿肯，但在拿到木吉他后的两年里，我所做的全部事情就是想把它弄得更大声。我偶然发现了接触式麦克风，这是一种设备，一个你可以直接贴在吉他顶部的麦克风，用来放大声音。它会拾取木材的实际振动，从而拾取吉他的声音。30年后，我正在看体操。平衡木是一种合成树脂材料，运动员们在上面平衡，做空翻，在上面做各种各样的动作。我听到这个平衡木的声音，我说，我的意思是，那里有一种共振
that we cannot hear, that someone probably has never heard. Is that a new texture that we should put into the mix? And by the time we put the contact microphones on there, it gave a new level of depth because the contact microphone hears the vibration in the entire bar. Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaaaa, Niharaaaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaaaaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaa, Niharaaaaa What? Be it for fun! For sets, Roger Federer to serve. Ready? Ready. 2008.
是我们听不到的，是别人可能从未听过的。这是我们应该加入混音中的新质感吗？当我们把接触式麦克风放在上面时，它提供了一个新的深度水平，因为接触式麦克风听到了整个杠的振动。尼哈拉，尼哈拉……什么？为了好玩！第一盘，罗杰·费德勒发球。准备好了吗？准备好了。2008年。
Here we go. Play. In 2008, the team responsible for the sound of the Wimbledon-Mins file was nominated for a BAFTA award. I love atmosphere. That is my job as far as I'm concerned. It's the atmosphere that you generate that makes people be there. that makes people be there. I'm Bill Wiston and I'm the sound supervisor who did the sound for the 2008 Wimbledon tennis finals, the Gents. That's the sound of Wimbledon. That hush, the bouncing of the ball on the court.
我们开始吧。比赛。2008年，负责温网男子单打决赛声音的团队获得了英国电影学院奖提名。我喜欢氛围。就我而言，这就是我的工作。你营造的氛围能让人身临其境。我是比尔·温斯顿，我是负责2008年温网男子网球单打决赛声音的声音主管。那是温网的声音。那种安静，球在场地上弹跳的声音。
That atmosphere is the sort of thing that I am trying to bring into the home. That hush, when everybody is fully expectant of something brilliant to happen. There's lots of microphones on the court. Basically the court is covered by a very nice small stereo mic. Stuck on the back of the court just above the centre-line judges' head. So that occasionally causes an interesting moment when they shout. Hi! I'm not that excited with the call of the right place line, but what was the call of the front? Mae'r ymwch i'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy'n fwy And you will no doubt have seen on close-ups of the chair when the contestants are sitting either side of the chair during changeovers that you have an array of microphones actually
这种氛围正是我试图带入千家万户的东西。那种安静，当每个人都满怀期待地等待着精彩的事情发生时。场上有许多麦克风。基本上整个球场都被一个非常好的小型立体声麦克风覆盖着。粘在球场后方、中线裁判头部的正上方。所以这偶尔会引起一个有趣的时刻，当他们大喊时。嗨！我对正确边线的判罚不是那么兴奋，但前场的判罚是什么？……毫无疑问，当你在特写中看到裁判椅时，当参赛选手在换边时坐在椅子两侧，你会发现其实有一排麦克风
on the chair. And those are used to these days ever since Mr McEnroe's outburst to try and pick up anything that's interesting and said to the Ompaer. Crawford serves, lines get to back in the centre, Crawford drives into the net, that's bad, man for him. The way tennis used to be covered way back in the early days was to actually have what was called an apple and biscuit microphone. They'd stick that over the top of the umpire's chair so you've got a bit of umpire on as well as the rather distant smashes of the ball. His service puts him at such an advantage even when Crawford gets it back, if he's able to come up and value it and put the more where he likes.
在椅子上。这些麦克风自麦肯罗先生爆发以来，一直被用来试图捕捉对裁判所说的任何有趣的话。克劳福德发球，球落回中路，克劳福德将球抽进网内，对他来说这太糟糕了。早期报道网球的方式实际上是使用一种叫做苹果和饼干麦克风的东西。他们把它粘在裁判椅的顶部，这样你既能听到一点裁判的声音，也能听到相当遥远的击球声。他的发球让他占据了如此巨大的优势，即使克劳福德把球接了回来，如果他能上前截击并把球打到他喜欢的地方。
Crawford returns the service and it's out. Any love? When I first joined outside broadcasts, they were still doing mono. It was early 80s and I was asked to do court two in stereo to see if we could develop a technique for doing that. I came to in the end using quite a posh and expensive and not very weatherproof microphone which is a beautiful stereo microphone but really normally used for covering orchestras and then that meant that your players were actually moving around, left to right, as they
克劳福德回球，出界了。零比零？当我刚加入外景转播时，他们还在做单声道。那是80年代初，我被要求在二号场地做立体声，看看我们能否开发出一种这样做的方法。我最后使用了一个相当昂贵、高级且不太防风雨的麦克风，这是一个美丽的立体声麦克风，但通常用于录制管弦乐队，这意味着你的球员实际上是在左右移动，当他们
ran around the court. 15 ohm. That's now evolved into a surround technique where you have not only the crowd and the players in front of you, but the crowd also goes all the way around the back of you. So when you're in the middle of a cheering crowd, when it's been accorded well, the surround really involves you in the play, if you like. It's like actually being there. 3015. The dynamic range, the difference between the quietest noise and the loudest noise doesn't have to keep you on your toes.
在场上奔跑时。15平。这现在已经演变成了一种环绕声技术，你不只有你面前的观众和球员，观众还一路延伸到你的身后。所以当你置身于欢呼的人群中间时，如果录音效果好，环绕声真的会让你沉浸在比赛中，如果你愿意的话。就像身临其境一样。30比15。动态范围，即最安静的声音和最响亮的声音之间的差异，并不需要让你时刻保持警惕。
If you've got the court mix on a fader and you take that fader down in anticipation of it getting very loud on the court and you do it ahead of time, you ruin the effect. What you've got to do is time it in such a way that the second that that quiet atmosphere changes into the huge roar from the crowd, you've got a split second to fade down that effect, if you like. APPLAUSE Over the years, I've managed to develop this sort of sixth sense in a way that I can guess pretty much now, nine times out of ten, what the crowd's going to do. Getting that exciting stillness, anticipation,
如果你把球场混音放在推子上，并且在预料到球场声音会变得非常大时提前把推子拉下去，你就毁了这个效果。你必须掌握好时机，在安静的氛围变成观众巨大咆哮声的那一秒钟，你只有一秒钟的时间把这个效果推下去，如果你愿意的话。掌声多年来，我设法培养了这种第六感，以至于现在十有八九我基本上都能猜到观众会做什么。获得那种令人兴奋的寂静、期待，
and then this huge roar when it's all developed into something really wonderful. And of course, keeping the commentator on top of it. Well, that would be the right time to serve your first ace. And I'll now, with a second set point. What was brilliant about that particular final was that they let it breathe. They didn't talk all over it all the time. I have had a number of people say to me,
然后在一切发展成非常精彩的事情时发出巨大的咆哮。当然，还要让评论员跟上节奏。嗯，这会是发你的第一个ACE球的好时机。现在进入第二个盘点。那场决赛的精彩之处在于他们让它有了呼吸的空间。他们没有一直喋喋不休。我遇到过不少人对我说，
is there any way that we could have a feed without a commentator? I think that would be something that people would really appreciate. You could add your own commentary then. But juicers of the old school would tell a commentator to shut up. I don't think many do now. I'm Barry Davis and for a few years I've been a commentator on various things. When a goal is scored, I would just call my commentator for his position just for five wind up the sound of the crowd and then let him come in. I used to try and make a thought in my mind that if you can't think of what to say, say nothing, which is actually the best policy, but invariably one forgets that from time to time, we don't carry it away with the emotion. Euro 96 when England played Germany in the semi-final. I can remember very well.
有没有可能提供没有评论员的音轨？我想这会是人们真正感激的事情。那样你就可以添加你自己的评论了。但老派的导播会叫评论员闭嘴。我想现在没多少人这么做了。我是巴里·戴维斯，多年来我一直是各种赛事的评论员。当进球时，我会为了他的位置只呼叫我的评论员五秒钟，以放大观众的声音，然后让他进来。我过去常常在心里告诉自己，如果你想不出说什么，就什么也别说，这实际上是最好的政策，但往往人们有时会忘记这一点，被情绪冲昏了头脑。96年欧洲杯，英格兰在半决赛对阵德国。我记得很清楚。
Four, I would have thought something close to ten minutes before the teams came out. So much good sound from around the stadium. Just with a few observations and commentators. Everyone joining in. The famous... those who come to support the opposition. And those only well known to their friends. People may be unaware of what I'm trying to achieve, but if you've got a bunch of people sitting at home going,
在球队出场前差不多近十分钟。球场周围传来了很多美妙的声音。只有一些观察和评论员的声音。每个人都加入进来。著名的……那些来支持对手的人。以及那些只有他们的朋友才熟悉的人。人们可能没有意识到我在试图实现什么，但如果你有一群人坐在家里说，
gosh, wasn't that a terrific match. They don't actually say gosh wasn't the sound terrific but you know that is so much part of it. In a football match what we do nowadays is to have a stereo atmosphere mic and then 12 mics around the pitch, which you fade up and down as the ball moves up and down the pitch, in other words chasing the ball around, so you can get the kicks and the scuffles and the shouting and all that sort of stuff. It's a difficult technique to get across to people who haven't done it before. It's anticipating where the ball is going to go. Personally, I don't favor the system of fixed microphones around the pitch that Bill describes.
天哪，那不是一场精彩的比赛吗。他们其实不会说天哪声音太棒了，但你知道那是其中很大一部分。在足球比赛中，我们现在做的是拥有一个立体声环境麦克风，然后在球场周围放置12个麦克风，随着球在球场上下移动而向上或向下推拉推子，换句话说就是追着球跑，这样你就可以听到踢球声、争抢声、喊叫声以及诸如此类的东西。对于没有做过的人来说，这是一项很难掌握的技术。这是在预测球会去哪里。就个人而言，我不赞成比尔所描述的在球场周围放置固定麦克风的系统。
I prefer to use four roving operators who each point a directional microphone at the action. They follow the action. I believe that this gives a better, more defined kick sound and a some method I've used at the last four Olympics and we're using London for the 2012 football events. What you're hearing now is a game from the Athens Olympics in 2004. The In every Olympic games, I try to rush of the excitement and entertainment value. And certainly, winter sports are fun because you're trying to convey a sense of speed and motion.
我更喜欢使用四个巡回摄像操作员，每个人都将定向麦克风对准动作。他们跟着动作走。我相信这能提供更好、更清晰的踢球声音，这也是我在过去四届奥运会上使用的方法，我们将在2012年伦敦奥运会的足球比赛中使用它。你现在听到的是2004年雅典奥运会的一场比赛。在每一届奥运会中，我都在努力追求兴奋感和娱乐价值。当然，冬季运动很有趣，因为你试图传达速度和运动感。
I've always enjoyed the sound of Bob's sled. In Vancouver, there were 44 cameras. At each camera position, there was a distinctly different oral perspective and I was trying to put the viewer, the listener, into place of the athlete. And I made every camera position a sound zone. Some people may say that 284 microphones is a bit excessive. But you have to remember that every camera perspective, every visual perspective for the viewing audience has a different sound texture and a different sound color. It's like a piece of music that if you just sit and listen to the crowd, you hear like how it swells and dives and peaks and then suddenly bursts, it sounds to me like an orchestra.
我一直很喜欢雪车的声音。在温哥华，有44台摄像机。在每个摄像机位置，都有一个明显不同的听觉视角，我试图把观众、听众置于运动员的位置。我让每个摄像机位置都成为一个声音区。有些人可能会说284个麦克风有点过头了。但你必须记住，观众的每一个摄像机视角、每一个视觉视角都有不同的声音质感和不同的声音色彩。这就像一首音乐，如果你只是坐着听人群的声音，你会听到它是如何起伏、达到顶峰然后突然爆发的，在我听来，这就像一个管弦乐队。
I'm Rob Nox. I'm a sound effects recordist for movies in Hollywood. I get hired by the movie studios to record sounds specifically for their movie. For example, if you have a specific sports movie, be it horse racing, hockey, figure skating, football, basketball, they bring me into capture the essence of the crowds and the game itself.
我是罗布·诺克斯。我是好莱坞电影的声音特效录音师。电影制片厂雇我去专门为他们的电影录制声音。例如，如果你有一部特定的体育电影，无论是赛马、曲棍球、花样滑冰、橄榄球、篮球，他们都会把我请去捕捉观众和比赛本身的精髓。
The sound of the basketballs, the sound of horses hooves, horses breathing, players tackling each other, all that kind of good stuff. So they bring me in so that they can recreate the feeling of being really into that event when you see the movie. The game of their lives, it was the greatest team in any sport I have ever seen. The game of their lives is a football movie, the 1950 US men's national soccer team that was competing in the World Cup in Rio in Brazil and they went on to be England
篮球的声音、马蹄声、马的呼吸声、球员们互相冲撞的声音，诸如此类美妙的声响。所以他们把我请去，是为了在你看电影时，能重现那种真正融入其中的身临其境感。《他们的比赛》是我见过的任何体育项目中阵容最豪华的球队。这是一部关于足球的电影，讲述了1950年参加巴西里约热内卢世界杯的美国国家男子足球队，他们后来对阵的是英格兰队。
Which was shocking at the time because England was the best team on the planet and America was probably One of the worst teams. I was asked to go down to record football crowds for the movie in North America We don't have football crowds that are that exciting and ran bunches. I went to Brazil and I recorded football games. I went to Marumbi Stadium to record a game between Brazil and Bolivia, and the crowd was insane. I would just move around the stadium and listen for pockets of chanting and cheering or loud fans and listening for the energy. They are out of their mind singing in huge 10 foot drums.
这在当时令人震惊，因为英格兰是世界上最强的球队，而美国可能是最弱的球队之一。我应邀去为电影录制足球场上的观众助威声。在北美，我们没有那种如此狂热且规模庞大的足球观众。我去了巴西，录制了足球比赛。我去了马拉卡纳体育场录制巴西队和玻利维亚队的比赛，观众简直疯狂极了。我会在体育场四处走动，寻找歌唱声、欢呼声或大声喊叫的球迷的聚焦点，去聆听那种能量。他们疯狂地歌唱，敲着巨大的十英尺高的鼓。
When you can feel someone screaming and their guts are coming out as they're yelling, that's going to translate when you hear it in the movie. So I'm looking to record the people that are really passionate and into it. And so I would set up near them. I had a handheld recorder. I'd try to not let them know I was recording. So I didn't want to change their performance.
当你能感受到有人在声嘶力竭地尖叫，连内脏都要随着呐喊声涌出来时，这种感觉在你从电影里听到时就会传递出来。所以我想要录制那些真正充满激情、全身心投入的人。于是我就在他们附近架设设备。我拿着一个手持录音机。我尽量不让他们知道我在录音，因为我不想改变他们的表现。
Hey! Good work! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey! If you have people in the loop group, you know, actors, they're not going to go that deep
嘿！干得好！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿！如果你让配音组的人（也就是演员们）来做，他们是不会投入到那种深度的，
and scream like a fan and an audience welcome. It's amazing. When you can recreate with real people that energy, that's the way to do a sports movie. That's a feel! Yeah! Sound puts you in the actual environment, and it really does create an emotional response. My name is Gordon Dürerty. I am the studio audio director, Adelaide Tronik-Arts Canada, specifically the sports video game end of the company.
也不会像真正的球迷和观众那样发出欢迎的尖叫。这太神奇了。当你能用真人重现那种能量时，这才是制作体育电影的正确方式。那种感觉！太棒了！声音能把你带入实际的环境中，并且它确实能引发情感共鸣。我叫戈登·杜尔蒂。我是加拿大艺电公司（EA Canada）工作室音频总监，专门负责公司的体育电子游戏业务。
So we make games like FIFA, hockey, soccer, American football, golf, pretty much the entire range of sports. We're taking a scientific approach to a very emotional process, which is, let's re-analyze how crowds work. Instead of this big wash of sound where everything's happening at once, because that guy in the corner there whose face is painted purple, and he's got his team shirt on, and he's got a big drum, and he's trying to get his corner of the stadium all riled up.
所以我们制作诸如FIFA、冰球、足球、美式橄榄球、高尔夫等游戏，几乎涵盖了所有的体育项目。我们正在以科学的方法来对待一个非常感性的过程，那就是：重新分析观众的声音是如何运作的。而不是那种所有声音同时发生的一片喧哗，因为角落里的那个家伙把脸涂成了紫色，穿着球队队服，带着一个大鼓，正试图把体育场那个角落的气氛调动起来。
Maybe a wave starts around the stadium, or maybe it doesn't. So our future push is, let's get into actually modeling all riled up. Maybe a wave starts around the state and maybe it doesn't. So, you know, our future push is, let's get into actually modeling how crowds behave and how these different particles of sound actually interact to create a large crowd. We work a lot at how can we keep improving the actual game experience. We try to bring it down as authentic as possible, but then we have to go beyond because normally you would not hear the details of the sound on the pitch on TV, but as a gameplay you expect to hear the kicks. For this last South African world cup, we hired people in South Africa to record the crowds.
也许体育场里会掀起人浪，也许不会。所以我们未来的推进方向是，真正去建模观众的行为方式，以及这些不同的声音颗粒是如何相互作用来营造宏大的人声背景的。我们花了大量时间研究如何不断改进实际的游戏体验。我们尽量让它尽可能地真实，但随后我们必须超越真实，因为通常你在电视上是听不到球场上的声音细节的，但作为玩家，你希望能听到击球声。对于上届南非世界杯，我们在南非雇人录制了观众的声音。
We have to build a game quite a few months in advance of the event. We actually had the crowds come back from South Africa and I went down to one of the audio sound guys rooms and I kept hearing the speed hives going on. What is this thing? This is driving me bonkers. Can we not turn that thing off or down? You guys know this is this vuvazela thing. It's part of the thing but you have to have this or it's not authentic. So we actually put a mute button on, finally, to say that you can mute it or lower the volume of it. And then when the actual World Cup started in South Africa, people were saying, you know,
我们必须在赛事举办前好几个月就把游戏开发出来。实际上，当南非的录音素材送回来时，我去了一个音效师的房间，一直听到嗡嗡的呜呜祖拉声在响。这是什么东西？这快把我逼疯了。我们就不能把这东西关掉或者把声音调小一点吗？你们也知道这就是那个呜呜祖拉。它是其中的一部分，但你必须有这个，否则就不真实。所以我们最后实际上加了一个静音按钮，这样你就可以将它静音或者调低音量。然后，当南非世界杯真正开幕时，人们纷纷表示：
how come the TV channels can't just put a mute button like they do in the actual video game? Dovina is another one of my favorite sports. This is a great example of really trying to isolate the micro-sounds of the sport. You can really separate the above sounds in the swimming hall and the below sounds, the underwater sounds. Really conveys the sense of focus and the sense of isolation of the athlete. We have microphones on the handrails as the divers walk up. You can hear their hands, you can hear their feet, you can hear them breathing. Eyes, eyes, eyes. I'm five. Oh. We have a microphone at the bottom of the pool under the water.
为什么电视频道不能像电子游戏里那样直接加个静音按钮呢？跳水是我最喜欢的另一项运动。这是一个努力孤立该运动微观声音的绝佳例子。你可以清楚地把游泳馆上方的声音和下方的声音（水下声音）区分开来。这真正传达了运动员的专注感和孤独感。当跳水运动员走上来时，我们在扶手上安装了麦克风。你能听到他们的手声，听到他们的脚声，听到他们的呼吸声。眼睛，眼睛，眼睛。我是五号。哦。我们在泳池底部水下放置了一个麦克风。
The athlete goes under the water, we shift the perspective to just them in the underwater sound. You hear the bubbles. You get the complete sense of isolation, the complete after hearing the coverage in Barcelona of the 92 Olympics. There were things that were missing. The easy things were there. The third in the impact of the target. That's a no-brainer in a little bit of the athlete as they're getting ready. But it probably goes back to the movie Robin Hood.
当运动员潜入水下时，我们将视角切换到他们专属的水下声音。你能听到气泡声。你会有完全的孤独感，在听了巴塞罗那92年奥运会的报道后，感觉一切都齐全了。一些简单的声音都在。击中目标的撞击声。在准备阶段运动员发出的一点声音也是不言而喻的。但这可能要追溯到电影《罗宾汉》。
I have a memory of the sound, and I have an expectation. So I was going, okay, what would be really, really cool in archery to take it up a notch? And the obvious thing was the sound of the arrow going through the air to the target, which was the type of sound.
我对这种声音有记忆，也有期待。所以我在想，好吧，在射箭中加入什么会非常非常酷，能让它更上一层楼？显而易见的事情就是箭穿过空气飞向靶子的声音，这就是那种声音。
So we looked at a little thing, called a boundary microphone. They lay flat, it was flatter than a pack of cigarettes, I put a little windshield on it and I put it on the ground between the athlete and the target and it completely opened up the sound to something different. And then I pulled the point, total 0.7-1.
所以我们看了一种小东西，叫做边界麦克风。它们是平着放的，比一包香烟还要薄，我给它套上了一个小防风罩，把它放在运动员和靶子之间的地上，它彻底把声音打开，呈现出完全不同的效果。然后我拉动靶尖，总共0.7-1。
For some reason, directors don't like to see the microphones. They do like hearing good sound, but there is a resistance to actually seeing microphones in the picture, which is one of the challenges that we have. And the boundary microphone fulfilled that challenge because you could creep the microphone closer to the actual source. Because the ampah has to line up the boat's first wall and get them into line and see if they're both straight.
出于某种原因，导演们不喜欢看到麦克风。他们确实喜欢听到好声音，但对于在画面中实际看到麦克风存在着抵触情绪，这是我们面临的挑战之一。而边界麦克风正好解决了这个挑战，因为你可以把麦克风悄悄靠近真正的声源。因为裁判必须把船的首墙排成一线，让他们排成一列，看看他们是否都笔直。
The ampah has been down, he came down about a quarter of an hour ago to line up the actual stake bridge. The engine of the launch has started up and the excitement is growing quite visibly or orderly on both sides of the river now. I wonder if you can hear them on this type of a. Well, we find ourselves on a quite glorious day down on the Thames of the boat race and it's absolutely magnificent. Paul Davis, I'm an executive producer with BBC Sport, look after tennis, rugby union, golf, the boat race and a few other things. Sound is, it's a hidden jewel, isn't it, really? I mean, I think it's one of those things that one takes for granted because for obvious reasons you can't see it and when it's going great,
裁判长已经下去了，他大约在十五分钟前下来对准实际的起航桥。艇上的发动机已经启动，现在河两岸的兴奋情绪显而易见、井然有序。不知道你能不能在这种声音里听到他们。我们在泰晤士河畔迎来了极其辉煌的一天，这是赛艇对抗赛，绝对太棒了。我是保罗·戴维斯，BBC体育的执行制片人，负责网球、橄榄球、高尔夫、赛艇和一些其他事务。声音是一颗隐藏的明珠，对吧？我的意思是，我认为这是那种被人理所当然看待的事物，因为显而易见的原因你看不到它，当它运行完美时，
no one sort of refers to it, when it it goes wrong there is literally a deathly silence. I'm a huge supporter of sound in outside broadcast television and I think the guys that we work with really respect that. My name's Andy James, I'm a sound supervisor. We're at the other boat race at Putney and my job is about augmenting what you're seeing with what you hear. Everything we've done has been fine. Okay, I've saved my own pre-delay. Whenever I look at a shot, I want to try and better it with a sound.
没有人会去提及它，而当它出错时，简直是一片死寂。我是电视户外直播声音的坚定支持者，我认为我们合作的伙伴们真的很尊重这一点。我叫安迪·詹姆斯，是一名音频主管。我们在普特尼的另一场赛艇比赛现场，我的工作是用你听到的声音来增强你所看到的画面。我们做的一切都很好。好吧，我已经保存了我自己的预延迟。每当我看到一个镜头，我都想尝试用声音让它变得更好。
That's always my aim. So Paul cuts up a really, really good shot of the crews and you can see the looks on their faces. I want to hear every bit of effort they're putting into that stroke and that's really what our job is about. Make sure that every shot Paul cuts up we can match it with sound and make it even better. I'm looking at the gym at the opposite of the bowed house. There's a nice lower balcony that's very clear and
这一直是我的目标。所以保罗剪辑了一个非常非常好的船员镜头，你能看到他们脸上的表情。我想听到他们付出的每一分努力，这就是我们工作的意义所在。确保保罗剪辑的每一个镜头我们都能用声音与之匹配，并让它变得更好。我正在看船屋对面的健身房。那里的低层阳台视野非常开阔，
would look very good I think. Quite often a lot of the motivation for directing an outside broadcast is visually driven but often I think that can come from sound as well. And if we have two very motivated coxes and they're both mic'd up and they're delivering some outstanding sound then there's a real motivation A to hear that sound, to understand what they're delivering instruction wise and actually just to add atmosphere as well, then that's hugely motivating in terms of going visually to their cameras to see the cocks delivering it and then how the rows are reacting to it as well. So those motivational reasons
我想效果会非常好。很多时候，导演一场户外直播的动力是由视觉驱动的，但我认为这往往也可以由声音驱动。如果我们有两个非常有激劲的舵手，他们都佩戴了麦克风并且传出了极佳的声音，那么就会有一种真正的动力，A是听到这个声音，理解他们下达的指令，实际上也是为了增加氛围，这在视觉上去寻找他们的摄像机来看到舵手下达指令以及船员们如何对此做出反应方面具有巨大的激励作用。所以这些出于动机的原因
for hearing sound I think is great, rather than it just being wallpaper. We're passing the boat houses now, we're just going to take the Oxford Stroke. Now then, in, out, one, out, two, out, three, out. We're sort of bleeding through Georgie, but again, really good. I've got three and four of the coxies, but I don't have one and two. Okay, seven boat house and eight boat house. So Oxford on seven. On the boat race, we've got about six different shore sites
为了听到声音，我认为这很棒，而不是仅仅把它当成背景墙。我们现在正在经过船屋，我们马上要接通牛津大学的划手。好，进，出，一，出，二，出，三，出。乔治的声音有点漏过来，不过依然很好。我有舵手的第三道和第四道，但我没有第一道和第二道。好的，第七船屋和第八船屋。所以在赛艇对抗赛中，我们大约有六个不同的岸边站点
all the way down the course. We're at Putney at the moment, which is where the boats start. And we've got various stereo effects mics up and down the towpath. And then as we move from site to site, moving down the course, we have local effects mics there that are radio link back to us here where I can mix them in to the main
沿著整个赛道分布。我们目前在普特尼，也就是赛艇起点。我们在整个拖船小道上设置了各种立体声效果麦克风。然后，随著我们从一个站点移动到另一个站点，顺着赛道向下移动，我们在那里设有本地效果麦克风，它们通过无线电链路连回我们这里，在这里我可以将它们混入主
sound. We also have mics on the crew boats themselves and on the chase boats, so we can pick out the various different effects that we need as the boats move off down the river. The time has come. We start off the first half of the programme, we'll all be a presentation element when the presenters will be introducing what's going on, Clair Bauding will be with us. And this is the time, their time. Good afternoon, it's just gone according to four, we are live in the boat house of last year's winning crew Cambridge University.
声音中。我们的赛艇船只本身以及追逐船上也装有麦克风，这样当赛艇在河上向下移动时，我们可以挑选出我们需要的各种不同效果。时机已到。我们将开始节目的前半部分，这将是一个介绍环节，主持人将介绍正在发生的事情，克莱尔·鲍丁将和我们在一起。这就是时刻，他们的时刻。下午好，刚刚过了四点，我们在去年冠军船队剑桥大学的船屋进行现场直播。
So that's the first element and then we move into the race itself and I'm basically moving along my sound desk from left to right. Starting for... Just give us five minutes, Joe. Hi. I've got a 96-fader mixing desk here and I'm starting from the left hand end. I've got my commentary mic stand when in. The first stroke is so important.
所以这是第一部分，然后我们进入比赛本身，我基本上在调音台上从左到右移动。开始为……乔，给我们五分钟。嗨。我这里有一个96推子的调音台，我从左端开始。我有我的评论麦克风支架。第一桨至关重要。
It has to be good. 600 more to come but the first one is the platform which is the best. We've got various high-distant effects mics, one up on the hoist, which gives them a panoramic view of Patney. Then we move on down towards I like to backfade the 41 by now,
它必须很好。还有600米要划，但第一桨是最好的平台。我们有各种高处的远距离效果麦克风，一个在升降机上，它能提供普特尼的全景。然后我们继续向下，我喜欢现在淡出41号，
we're into mics in the boat houses themselves. Then we're kind of into the race itself, the start of the race, and we've got the umpires, both as the umpires get the race started. Then there's the Oxford and Cambridge boats themselves, and there's two effects mics that hopefully pick up the sound of the rowing. The coxies on the boats have a mic on them, personal mic on them. Yeah, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice 20 seconds 20 Pass it No! Jenny ready for a 4-10 10 10 10 10
我们进入了船屋本身的麦克风。然后我们有点进入比赛本身，比赛的开始，我们有裁判，当裁判开始比赛时。然后是牛津和剑桥的船只本身，有两个效果麦克风希望能捕捉到划船的声音。船上的舵手身上有一个麦克风，个人麦克风。好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好落后三分之一艇身，
10 10 10 10 10 10 Sometimes the language that comes from the Cox isn't broadcastable so we have to have an alternative to go to and that's part of the on a live job like this you've got to work out what the cox is are saying is it transmittable but nevertheless what they're saying is it gives you really good information I'm not right there boys. I'm not right there. Turn it on the bend boy. Steading third of a length down.
有时舵手说的话是不能播出的，所以我们必须有一个替代方案，这是像这样现场工作的一部分，你必须弄清楚舵手在说什么，它适合广播吗？尽管如此，他们说的话确实能给你提供非常好的信息，我不在那里，伙计们。我不在那里。在弯道处转弯，伙计。稳住，落后三分之一艇身。
Shining on boys. Shining on the bend boy. Steading on the bend boy. Steading third of a length down. Shining on boys. Steading on the bend boy. Steading on the bend boy. Steading third of a length down.
加把劲，伙计们。在弯道处加把劲，伙计。在弯道处稳住，伙计。稳住，落后三分之一艇身。加把劲，伙计们。在弯道处稳住，伙计。在弯道处稳住，伙计。稳住，落后三分之一艇身。
Shining on boys. Steading on the bend boy. Steading on the bend boy. Steading third of a length down. Shining on boys. Steading on the bend boy. Steading on the bend boy The boys stay long on the road. Just think about that. The boys for ten. Think about that, boys. Ready? Go! Coming into the pit! Woo!
加把劲，伙计们。在弯道处稳住，伙计。在弯道处稳住，伙计。稳住，落后三分之一艇身。加把劲，伙计们。在弯道处稳住，伙计。在弯道处稳住，伙计。小伙子们在航道上坚持住。想想看。为了十桨，想想看，伙计们。准备？走！进入维修区！呜！
Then we're into the various shore sites. So there's another 15 fades down there of shore sites which will be able to pick up the crowds that are locally watching from the various different places on the race. They tend to give us a good bit of colour because they're all having parties. It's about building up a multi-layered or rural picture. Ops from there, heading towards Victory. It is all that's starting there. It is Chazic Bridge at the top of your picture and the finish line sits just before that. to the left hand side and Simon went to leave this his work again, shouting not letting
接着我们来到各个岸边现场。那里的岸边现场还有大约15个信号传送点，它们能够捕捉到在比赛沿途各个不同地点现场观看的人群。它们往往能给我们带来很好的氛围，因为大家都在开派对。这就像是构建一幅多层次或质朴的画面。从那里出发，朝着胜利纪念碑前进。所有这些都在那里开始。那是你画面上方的查西克桥，终点线就在它的正前方。在左侧，西蒙又去离职他的工作，大喊大叫，没有放
up. They will not let up Oxford. Cambridge run for the winning post. Oxford, two on the two lengths behind, two on half lengths behind. Flags gone down, Cambridge run, one, Cambridge run by two on a half lengths behind, flags gone down, Cambridgeer 1, Cambridgeer 1 by two and a half lengths. Cambridge have won the boat race of 1933. Cambridge still had a slightly higher stroke rate, but into the final straight they come. And the pace, of course, from Oxford has dropped slightly, hunched the girls' time,
松。他们不会放松，牛津。剑桥向着终点线冲刺。牛津，落后两艇身，落后两艇半身。旗子落下了，剑桥冲刺，赢了，剑桥领先两艇半冲线，旗子落下了，剑桥1号，剑桥1号领先两艇半。剑桥赢得了1933年的赛艇比赛。剑桥的桨频依然略高一些，但他们进入了最后的直道。而牛津的速度，当然，略微有所下降，姑娘们的时间弯着腰，
but the jade is on the stun. As a spectator, you actually see very little of the race. You'll see the start, all the finish-ups and we're in between. What we can do is actually convey an atmosphere throughout the whole race for the viewer, so you actually get a much better experience. After the peak last year, in 2011, the Thames belongs to Oxford. To them, the victory, the smiles, the celebrations, the spoils, everything is theirs and Cambridge had for his left. I think it's all about layering. With pictures, there's a degree of layering, but it's fairly clear cut. Literally, you're cutting between pictures.
但翡翠大受震撼。作为一个观众，你其实只能看到比赛的很少一部分。你会看到开始、所有的冲刺以及我们在中间所做的一切。我们能做的是，在整场比赛中为观众传达一种氛围，让你获得好得多的体验。在2011年的巅峰之后，泰晤士河属于牛津。对他们而言，胜利、微笑、庆祝、战利品，一切都属于他们，而剑桥一无所有。我认为这全关乎层次感。对于画面来说，存在一定程度的层次感，但它相当明确。字面意思上，你就是在画面之间进行切换。
With the sound, I think you can build up the layers. Covering anthems, for example, during six nations. And whether you, when you go to the anthems shots of the teams, and you're tracking along the close-ups of the players, do you actually want to hear the choral singing of the stadium, or do you want to hear in all your respect the fairly poor singing of the individual players? That's an interesting mix that the sound guys have to deal with, because you want the personality and clearly they know the words but often they're not sung very well. If you didn't hear their sounds at all, then you'd feel a bit cheated. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, For years we used to sit with a radio mic on the referee but it wasn't transmitted.
至于声音，我认为你可以构建出层次。例如，在六国橄榄球赛期间覆盖国歌。当你去拍球队唱国歌的镜头，并沿着特写镜头追踪球员时，你究竟是想听到体育场的合唱，还是出于尊重，想听到个别球员相当糟糕的歌唱？这是一个音响师必须处理的有趣组合，因为你既想要个性，而且显然他们知道歌词，但通常他们唱得并不是很好。如果你根本听不到他们的声音，那你就会觉得有点被欺骗了。噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，多年来，我们习惯在裁判身上放一个无线话筒，但它并没有被转播。
And then eventually the rugby union officials decided to let us transmit this wonderful addition to the commentary. That's what it is. It's part of the commentary. And I think it adds so much. I don't think you could use the technique for football. Take the hits, please on contact. You make sure you go straight. You go straight. technique for football. Touch! Holes! Hey guys! So the addition of a microphone on the rugby referee opened up another dimension. It puts you right into the game. You can be the player. I believe that is the future of sports sound.
然后最终，橄榄球联盟的官员决定让我们转播这个对解说来说绝妙的补充。事实就是如此。它是解说的一部分。而且我认为它增添了如此多的内容。我不认为你能把这种技术用在足球上。请承受接触时的撞击。你要确保你走直线。你走直线。足球的技术。边线！洞！大家好！因此，在橄榄球裁判身上添加麦克风开启了另一个维度。它把你直接带入了比赛中。你可以成为那个球员。我相信那是体育之声的未来。
Microphones on the athletes and players themselves. If you can persuade them to wear them. Yep! microphones on the athletes and players themselves, if you can persuade them to wear them. And here's another sport that benefited hugely from this technique. We're trying to catch, we're trying to catch. Curling was introduced to the Olympics in 1988 when the winter Olympics went to Calgary and the rest of the world going curling. We're trying to catch, we're trying to catch. Calgary and the rest of the world going curling, curling. How are we going to make curling exciting? How are we going to introduce curling to the world?
运动员和球员自己身上的麦克风。如果你能说服他们佩戴的话。没错！运动员和球员自己身上的麦克风，如果你能说服他们佩戴的话。这里还有另一项从这项技术中获得巨大收益的运动。我们在努力追赶，我们在努力追赶。冰壶是在1988年冬季奥运会来到卡尔加里时被引入奥运会的，当时全世界都掀起了冰壶热。我们在努力追赶，我们在努力追赶。卡尔加里和全世界都在玩冰壶，冰壶。我们该如何让冰壶变得激动人心？我们该如何向世界介绍冰壶？
And early on we started putting microphones wireless, microphones on the curlers. That's all. Oh yeah, if we know that it's a pretty big pocket, if we freeze in the back we're not, no it's it. They're a strategy, they're encouraging each other, they're Or... They're a strategy.
早期我们开始在冰壶运动员身上安装无线麦克风。就这样。哦，是的，如果我们知道那是一个相当大的包，如果我们冻在后面，不，不是的，就是它。它们是一种策略，它们在互相鼓励，它们在……或者……它们是一种策略。
They're encouraging each other. They're talking, they're constantly talking. There's a lot of screaming. It's a very, very vocal sport. There's a half-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or-or- audience and it has really been a huge boost in the ratings and the interest in the sports. With a video game it's an interesting position in that you are the player on the field. You're also the viewer of the game, so you're sort of in this weird place where you're sort of a spectator, but you're also an active participant. What we found with the sound is that we had to pretty much exaggerate. For instance, on a boxing game, we record the real boxes, but we just don't get the clean sound to get like things like grunts and groans and punches and impacts.
它们在互相鼓励。它们在交谈，它们在不断地交谈。有很多尖叫声。这是一项非常、非常注重声音的运动。还有半……观众，它确实极大地提升了收视率和人们对这项运动的兴趣。对于电子游戏来说，这是一个很有趣的位置，因为你是场上的球员。你同时也是比赛的观众，所以你处于这种奇怪的境地，你既是旁观者，但你也是积极的参与者。我们在声音方面发现的是，我们几乎必须进行夸张。例如，在一款拳击游戏中，我们录制了真实的拳击手，但我们就是无法获得像喘息声、呻吟声、击打声和撞击声那样干净的声音。
So we go into a studio and sometimes we'll recreate a boxing ring to do the feet and the falls. And then what we'll do is we'll close Mike, it's called a foliardis, it's basically the people that do the footsteps and all the sort of hand props and everything for film and television. We'll have the person punch a punching bag or a side a bee for whatever and just get all of the actual punch sounds. A high, low, medium, hard, different angles. Then we'll get voice down to coming and do things like all the,
所以我们会走进录音棚，有时我们会重现一个拳击台来制作脚步声和摔倒声。然后我们要做的就是进行近距离收音，这被称为“拟音艺术”（Foley art），基本上就是为电影和电视制作脚步声、各种手持道具以及所有一切的人。我们会让演员击打沙袋、蜂箱或其他什么东西，然后只收集所有真实的击打声音。高、低、中、重，不同的角度。然后我们会让人声过来做各种，
the boxing sniffs and all the grunts and groans, and we'll then do things like, break celery and lard into a body impact sound to get like a cracking rib type of sound. So all of those elements we carefully craft in a studio environment, and then when we layer that back into the game and we blend that in and then we add the live crowds from the venues and we dress it all up, the whole net effect of that is that it does feel fairly authentic. On the tennis game called Grand Slam Tennis, what I did, and I stick a lot of tracking down, was try to get tapes from the French Open. It's similar, I got some tapes from Wimbledon as well.
拳击时的吸鼻声以及所有的喘息声和呻吟声，然后我们会做一些事情，比如把西芹和猪油捏碎来模拟身体撞击声，以获得肋骨断裂那种声音。因此，所有这些元素都是我们在录音棚环境中精心打造的，然后当我们将它们分层加回到游戏中并进行融合，接着再加入来自场馆的现场观众声音并将这一切包装起来，最终产生的整体效果就是它确实感觉相当真实。在一款名为《大满贯网球》（Grand Slam Tennis）的网球游戏中，我所做的是——我做了大量的追踪工作——试图获取法国网球公开赛的磁带。类似地，我也从温布尔登弄到了一些磁带。
So we were able to get a number of matches with different players and different sizes of venues and just basically extract the crowd from there. And Mac and Ro, the William sisters, grunts, they have very unique sort of streaks and screams that tennis players do. We were actually able to pull that off the tape as well. I think it was Venus said wow, you know, it sounds just like me serving. I said well, it is exactly're serving, because it is you serving that we extracted.
所以我们得以获得许多不同球员、不同规模场馆的比赛，并基本上从那里提取出了观众的欢呼声。还有麦肯罗、威廉姆斯姐妹的击球喘息声，网球运动员发出的那种非常独特的尖叫声。我们实际上也能从磁带中提取出这些声音。我想维纳斯曾说过，哇，你知道的，这听我说发球的声音简直一模一样。我说，嗯，这确实就是你发球的声音，因为这就是我们提取的你的发球声。
15. I was doing American car racing. They call it NASCAR. And this particular race was a half mile oval. And essentially, what would be considered a football type stadium with very high banking. The cars put out 140 decibels of sound, maybe more than you put 40 of those cars on a half mile track and it just sounds like a hornet nest. There's no real definition. Then all of a sudden the show is over and there supposedly is the roar of the crowd,
15。我当时在做美国赛车比赛。他们称之为NASCAR（纳斯卡赛车）。这场特定的比赛是一个半英里的椭圆形赛道。本质上，它将被视为一种带有非常高倾斜度的美式足球类型的体育场。赛车发出140分贝的声音，也许更多，当你把40辆这样的赛车放在一个半英里的赛道上时，听起来就像是一个大黄蜂窝。没有什么真正的清晰度。然后突然之间比赛结束了，本该有热烈的欢呼声，
but the producers screaming, I can hear the crowd, I can't hear the crowd. It's a very basic physics issue where the sound that I want or being massed or being drowned out by these cars. So I said, okay, you know, I learned my lesson. I went back to my home studio and I started pulling up some crowd samples and building different textures and things like that. So my next race, you know, when they showed the crowd, I started sneaking some stuff in. And when it came to the end of it, it was a very, very nice crowd swell. a very, very nice crowd as well. And the same producers, you know, you get in the out of the boys and you know, this is great. This is what I want. This is what we're trying to achieve. And then a week later he found out that I'd use the sample. And
但制作人大喊大叫，我能听到人群的声音，我听不到人群的声音。这是一个非常基础的物理问题，我想要的声音被这些赛车给掩盖或淹没了。所以我说，好吧，你知道的，我吸取了教训。我回到了家里的录音棚，开始调出一些观众的采样，并构建不同的纹理等等。所以在我的下一场比赛中，你知道的，当他们展示观众时，我开始偷偷塞入一些音效。而当比赛接近尾声时，那是一个非常非常棒的观众欢呼声浪。一个非常非常棒的观众欢呼声浪。同样的制作人，你知道的，你会融入其中，你知道的，这太棒了。这正是我想要的。这就是我们试图达到的效果。然后一周后他发现我用了采样，然后
then I get a call and said, you're cheating. And I'm saying, well, you know, all right, who am I cheating? Am I cheating the audience? No, the audience sees a crowd. The audience has certain expectations. You'll see a crowd, you hear a crowd. There's some sports that you just cannot capture the natural sound. Cross-country skiing, byathlon is another one because of the size of the course. And this has been further complicated because as the camera lenses have gone up 110, 120, 130,
我接到一个电话，说：“你在作弊。”我说：“好吧，你知道的，好吧，我在欺骗谁？我在欺骗观众吗？不，观众看到了观众。观众有某种期望。你看到观众，你就会听到观众的声音。有些运动你就是无法捕捉到自然的天然声音。越野滑雪，冬季两项是另一项因为赛道规模而难以捕捉的运动。这由于摄像机镜头的变大而变得更加复杂，从110倍、120倍、130倍，
140 to one, these cameras are able to see a half a kilometer or maybe a kilometer down the course. Now how do you replicate that sound? Essentially if if you've got cameras that are that far apart from each other, you're putting 20 or 30 microphones to fill as the athletes are coming to you, which is not practical. I am not a purist whatsoever in sound production. I truly believe that whatever the tool takes to deliver a high-quality, entertaining soundscape is all fair game. And that has caused some issues because I use samplers. What a sampler is, it's a keyboard that's attached to essentially a digital recorder.
到140比1，这些摄像机能够看到赛道前方半公里或一公里远的距离。现在你如何复制那种声音？本质上，如果你的摄像机彼此相距那么远，你就要放置20或30个麦克风来在运动员向你跑来时进行收音，这根本不切实际。在声音制作方面，我绝对不是一个纯粹主义者。我坚信，无论采用什么工具来呈现高质量、引人入胜的音景，都是完全可行的。这引发了一些问题，因为我使用了采样器。什么是采样器？它是一个连接到数字录音机本质上的键盘。
When you hit the key on the keyboard, it triggers the sound to play back and with the keyboard it also triggers with sensitivity meaning that if I hit the key real hard it'll have a little bit more of a harder attack and you can vary the pitch. If I hit a step. So for the ski end, it gives a sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh.
当你按下键盘上的一个键时，它会触发声音播放，并且配合键盘，它还能根据触感进行触发，这意味着如果我重重地按下这个键，它就会有一个更猛烈的起音，而且你可以改变音高。如果我踩下一级台阶。所以对于滑雪的结尾，它会发出嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶。
Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh.
嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶。
Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh. Sh my biggest problems was rowing. Rowing is a two kilometer course. They have four chase boats following the rowers and they have a helicopter.
嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶，嘶我遇到的最大问题是赛艇。赛艇是一条两公里的赛道。他们有四艘追逐艇跟随着赛艇运动员，他们还有一架直升机。
That's what they need to deliver the visual coverage of it. But the helicopter and the chase boat just completely wash out the sand. So no matter how good the microphones are, you cannot capture, you cannot reach, and isolate sound like you do visually. But people have expectations, okay? If you see the rovers, they have a sound that they're expecting. So what do we do? That afternoon we went out on a canoe with a couple of rowers and recorded stereo samples of the different type of effects that would be somewhat typical of an event. And then we loaded those recordings into a sampler and played them back to cover the shots of the boats.
那是他们用来提供视觉转播所需要的。但直升机和追逐艇的声音完全把声音给盖过去了。所以不管麦克风有多好，你都无法像视觉那样捕捉、触及并隔离声音。但人们有期望，对吧？如果你看到赛艇运动员，他们会有一个他们所期望的声音。那我们该怎么做？那天下午，我们带着几个赛艇运动员坐上一艘独木舟，录制了不同类型效果的立体声采样，这些效果对于一项赛事来说多少算是典型的。然后我们将这些录音加载到采样器中，并将它们回放出来，以掩盖船只的镜头。
The Australians have bitten something back from them, but not enough. Great Britain, gold medals, Stephen Redgrade, Matthew Benson, mission accomplished. Standby. And they're racing. Good evening to Spatch, although Victoria Spanches dropped back to last early, first to begin on the far side
澳大利亚人从他们那里扳回了一些劣势，但还不够。英国，金牌，史蒂芬·雷德格雷夫，马修·宾森，任务完成。待命。比赛开始了。晚上好，斯帕奇，尽管维多利亚·斯帕奇在早期落到了最后，但首先在远端开始的是
as Dan Ceeces is out there in the early stages going far two is. When we do our horse racing, you're not going to get somebody running around the course after the horses, because no way. And occasionally you will come across very close up pictures of the horses over the far side, which is done off one of our roving cameras.
当丹·西塞斯在早期阶段到外面去的时候，情况也是如此。当我们进行赛马转播时，你不会让某个人拿着话筒追着马跑全场，因为根本不可能。偶尔你会遇到远端马匹非常近距离的画面，那是通过我们的移动摄像机之一完成的。
But you have engine noise in that case, so therefore you wouldn't want a microphone on that, because all you would hear is the car revving up and the camera and cursing. So basically, the way you cover all that sort of stuff is to run a tape which has the sound of horses who's galloping, which is actually, if I remember rightly, a slowed down buffalo charge. Buffalo charge. And if they're doing hurdles you will have a tape which has the sound of somebody falling through a hedge, I suppose you call it, it's rustling all the time. So as they go through or over, hopefully the hurdle, you actually fade this up and if you're clever at it you vary the level a little bit so it sounds like several horses going through together. That's pretty much a standard thing and I think it's probably the same recording they've used for years.
但在那种情况下你有发动机的噪声，因此你不会想在那上面放一个麦克风，因为你听到的将只有汽车轰鸣声和摄像机以及咒骂声。所以基本上，你报道所有这类事情的方式是播放一卷磁带，里面有马奔跑的声音，如果我没记错的话，这实际上是放慢了的水牛冲锋声。水牛冲锋声。如果他们正在跨栏，你就会有一卷磁带，里面有某人掉进树篱的声音，我想你可以这么叫它，它一直在沙沙作响。所以当他们穿过或越过——希望是越过——栏杆时，你实际上把这个声音调大，如果你在这方面很聪明，你可以把音量稍微改变一点，听起来就像几匹马一起穿过去一样。这几乎是一件标准的事情，而且我认为这可能和他们多年来使用的一模一样。
Some horse racing events sound strange to me because they have this constant thundering sound and I can't tell if it's real or not. It's like in horse racing movies like I did see biscuit and all hat. I know you can hear the jockeys yelling and screaming at each other especially when they get tight on a turn. You hear the whips going. I recorded an Arabian horse. Arabians have a different gate than thoroughbreds. And I put four wireless mics or phones on each hoof. We wanted to control the speed of the horse, so we had the trainer run the horse in a circle with a rope. We wanted to control the movement because we have $12,000 in gear on the horse. He did kick one microphone off.
有些赛马比赛的声音对我来说听起来很奇怪，因为它们有这种持续的雷鸣般的声音，我分不清那是真是假。就像赛马电影里那样，比如我看过《奔腾年代》（Seabiscuit）和《一战成名》（All In）。我知道你能听到骑师们互相大喊大叫，尤其是当他们在转弯处挤在一起的时候。你能听到马鞭的声音。我录制了一匹阿拉伯马。阿拉伯马的步态与纯血马不同。我在每个蹄子上都放了四个无线麦克风或手机。我们想要控制马的速度，所以我们让驯马师用一根绳子牵着马绕圈跑。我们想要控制它的运动，因为我们在马身上安装了价值1.2万美元的装备。它确实踢掉了一个麦克风。
If I was going to be in charge for the sound of a real event, I would want to do like the Kentucky Derby and use mycoras around the track and have some onboard mics and then have mics in the crowd and have mics on the gate. Of course racing fans, they get really crazy when they're cheering. Does people are yelling? Come on! Come on! They're screaming at the top of their lungs and yelling.
如果我要负责一场真实赛事的音响，我会想要像肯塔基赛马大会（Kentucky Derby）那样，在赛道周围使用麦克风，在赛车上安装一些麦克风，然后在观众中放置麦克风，在起跑门上放置麦克风。当然，赛马迷们在欢呼时会变得非常疯狂。人们在尖叫吗？加油！加油！他们在大声尖叫和呐喊。
Sixty! Darts is all about fun, so you know we like to have a bit of fun as well with the sand. So what we do is we use the real sand of the dart hitting the board to trigger some samples and we play around with kick drums, snare drums, dustbin's falling over and anything else we can find and it just adds a bit of fun really to what can you know get a bit repetitive. It's not real but it's enhances. That's something that I think most of us involved in sport, try and do, try and enhance the experience. We tread the middle road between what's real and what's unreal.
六十！飞镖全在于乐趣，所以你知道我们也喜欢用声音来找点乐子。所以我们做的是，我们用飞镖击中靶盘的真实声音来触发一些采样，然后我们玩弄大军鼓、小军鼓、倒下的垃圾桶以及我们能找到的任何其他东西，它真的给本来可能变得有点重复的事情增添了一点乐趣。这不是真实的，但它提升了效果。这是我认为大多数参与体育运动的人都在努力做的事情，试图提升体验。我们在真实与不真实之间走中间路线。
If you're sitting at the side of a basketball court from a TV point of view, the producers want to hear the ball as it goes through the net, the swishing of the net. And that is certainly something that you do not ever hear in the basketball arena. You only hear that on TV because it's exciting. Samuel L. Jackson, I came to teach boys and you became men. This is our time! Coach Carter. For Coach Carter, the supervising sound editor wanted me to get the sound of the basketball, but he wanted... there's a ping. I don't know if you've ever heard of basketball, but when you bounce it, it goes,
如果你从电视的角度坐在篮球场边，制作人们希望听到篮球穿过篮网的声音，篮网的沙沙声。这绝对是你绝对不会在篮球场里听到的声音。你只能在电视上听到那个声音，因为它很激动人心。塞缪尔·杰克逊，我来教导男孩们，而你们成为了男人。这是我们的时刻！《卡特教练》（Coach Carter）。对于《卡特教练》，声音总监希望我录制篮球的声音，但他想要……有一种“叮”的声音。我不知道你有没有听过篮球的声音，当你拍它时，它会发出，
bounce ping! And it kind of has this high airy ring. We did this great rim stuff, like rim slams, rim hits, net wishes, and then we're trying to capture the sound of this ping. And we were right under the net, and I'm like, no, that's not it. It just sounds like the big thud of a basketball and the reverb in the room.
弹起，叮！它有点那种高亢空灵的嗡嗡声。我们做了一些很棒的篮筐音效，比如篮筐扣篮、篮筐撞击、篮网沙沙声，然后我们试图捕捉这种“叮”的声音。我们就站在篮网正下方，然后我想，不对，不是那个声音。听起来只像是篮球沉闷的撞击声和房间里的混响。
But then we went into the corner of the room, and I got elevated on the bleachers, and I had my microphone above the ball, and the guy slammed the ball on the ground, and then as the ball was coming up to my microphone, you hear the ping. I've always taken the approach to record the sound's documentary style like accurate and then I try to then find the next level up to go heightened reality. Sometimes you actually have to cheat a sound even bigger
但随后我们走进了房间的角落，我站到了看台上更高的地方，我的麦克风放在球的上方，然后那个人把球猛砸在地上，接着当球向上弹到我的麦克风时，你听到了那个“叮”的声音。我一直采取的方法是以纪录片风格录制声音，力求准确，然后我试图寻找下一个级别的声音，走向强化的现实。有时你实际上必须把声音做得更大，
to make it cut through. The thing that Hollywood does differently is it sounds huge. The movies sound big, they sound rich. It's definitely more theatrical than real. Just think fast and furious or die hard. As we've been doing this over the years, sort of emulating broadcast and enhancing it, the broadcasters have been listening to what we've been doing and then using our techniques back in the actual broadcast.
才能让它穿透出来。好莱坞做法不同的一点是，它听起来宏大。电影听起来很大气，听起来很丰富。它绝对比真实更有戏剧性。想想《速度与激情》（Fast and Furious）或《虎胆龙威》（Die Hard）。多年来我们一直在这样做，某种程度上是在模仿广播并对其进行增强，而广播公司一直在听我们所做的事情，然后在实际的广播中运用了我们的技术。
It's very interesting at ESPN, we told them, hey, we're trying to look at your broadcast model to try to sort of capture that classic broadcast thing, and then they told us, well, we've actually been playing your game, and we really love the fact that you guys, you know, push up the wooshes on the bats. So what they do now on broadcast is they actually zip those sounds up, meaning that, you know, when you listen to a baseball game now versus 10 years ago, you hear these big bat wooshes and arm throws and big fat catcher mitts, because they have mics located
这在ESPN非常有趣，我们告诉他们，嘿，我们正在试图研究你们的转播模式，以试图捕捉到那种经典的转播效果，然后他们告诉我们，嗯，我们实际上一直在玩你们的游戏，我们非常喜欢你们这些人，你知道的，把球棒挥舞的风声加强了。所以他们现在在转播中做的是，他们实际上把这些声音调得很高，这意味着，你知道的，当你现在听一场棒球比赛时，与10年前相比，你会听到这些巨大的球棒挥舞声、手臂投掷声和巨大的厚重捕手手套声，因为他们放置了麦克风
very close to capture those sounds. Many years ago the audio that people would have been used to expecting from a football match would have been the ground noise and that was all. Whereas now they expect to hear every kick, every grunt, every whistle of the referee because that's what they get used to hearing on video games, on films that have been post-dubbed. So we're always trying to match that sort of sand.
非常靠近以捕捉那些声音。多年前，人们习惯从一场足球比赛中期待的音频将是地面噪音，仅此而已。然而现在，他们期望听到每一次踢球、每一次喘息、裁判的每一次哨声，因为那是他们在电子游戏、在经过后期配音的电影中习惯听到声音。所以我们一直在努力匹配那种声音。
The challenge for me is to make sports on TV is engaging as film or video games. If we don't, we're going to lose out. But it's the challenge I welcome. I'm gearing up for London 2012 where the games will be presented in high-definition picture and certainly in surround sound. I'll be pushing to create the best, most involving, most detailed sound ever at the Olympics, and one thing that makes me very happy is I hear that the Vuvuzillas will be banned from the games. I leave you with one of my favorite sounds, the equestering jumping event. The Sound of Sport was presented by Dennis Baxter and produced by Peregrin Andrews. It was a fallen tree production originally produced for BBC Radio 4 in 2011.
对我的挑战是让电视上的体育运动像电影或电子游戏一样引人入胜。如果我们做不到，我们就会输掉。但我欢迎这个挑战。我正在为2012年伦敦奥运会做准备，那里的比赛将以高清画质呈现，当然还有环绕声。我将努力创造奥运会上最好、最引人入胜、最详细的声音，有一件事让我非常高兴，那就是我听说呜呜祖拉（Vuvuzelas）将被禁止在运动会使用。我用我最喜欢的声音之一留给你们，马术障碍赛。体育之声由丹尼斯·巴克斯特（Dennis Baxter）呈献，佩雷格林·安德鲁斯（Peregrin Andrews）制作。它是BBC广播四台在2011年最初制作的堕落之树（Fallen Tree）作品。
99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery Truffleman, and me, Roman Mars. The 99PI experience isn't just this episode you're hearing. We are also all on Twitter at Roman Mars, Sam listens, Katie Mingle and Truffleman. We're all still on Facebook, Tumblr, Instagram, Flickr, Spotify, SoundCloud. If you pick something out and search for 99% of visible, you're probably going to find us there. And you are always welcome to stop by our place at 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99%隐形节目组由萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、艾弗里·特鲁弗曼（Avery Truffleman）和我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）组成。99PI的体验不仅限于你正在听的这一集。我们也都活跃在Twitter上，帐号是Roman Mars、Sam listens、Katie Mingle和Truffleman。我们也都还在Facebook、Tumblr、Instagram、Flickr、Spotify和SoundCloud上。如果你挑出一项并搜索99%隐形，你很可能会在那里找到我们。而且随时欢迎你顺便来我们的网站99pi.org坐坐。电台塔皮奥。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。